hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and
apparently the very first real life
unboxing photos and videos have leaked
all over twitter as you can see this is
my twitter account right here and i am
going to be going through them looking
at them and analyzing them and giving
you guys my honest first impressions and
thoughts about the design of the new 14
and 16 inch macbook pros so this is
gonna be exciting now as you guys know
we've been making videos about the new
macbook pros with those new m1 pro and
m1 max chips going deep into the
architecture and explaining what
everything means as well as showing you
guys the leaked benchmarks which are
insane for these new macbook pros but
never mind that let's go ahead and get
straight into the new design and what i
think about it now it was originally
shared on reddit and now it is taken
down which i think somebody actually
broke their nda because this design is
not supposed to be revealed in real life
until monday when the embargo is lifted
but thankfully it's all over twitter and
i actually downloaded the photo but
before we get into that photo which
compares the 14 inch and the old 13 inch
i do want to show the very first
unboxing video which was also posted on
reddit and i actually downloaded it so
let's go ahead and watch it together all
right we got full screen right here
looks like some kind of a computer store
or something let's
turn up the volume there you go that's
the box as you can see we got the new
wallpaper
oh there you go
nice looks a little bit different than
before
all right that looks thick already that
already looks thicker than this m1
macbook pro right here
dang guys all right look at that you
have this huge
notch vent in the back which i don't
think these ones have oh
feels different oh all right guys we can
see a couple of interesting points we
have that new mac safe right there wow
super thin that looks nice you got the
two usbc's headphone jack and that new
kind of shape that's kind of flat but it
then curves into it
you'll have to like
oh
you have to pick it up
look at that black keyboard
all right
take off that paper
that looks nice
oh
look at that
notch that is crazy that's crazy
noticeable of course i would prefer not
to have any notch but i honestly think
that it's kind of like a branding thing
for apple and it totally sets it apart
from every other laptop out there and as
we all know the macbook pro text
that's right here is now gone they've
completely gotten rid of it but man
look at those
bezels
those are thin hello text
wow look at that
i've got to say
that looks clean honestly when i first
saw that notch in apple's event
it was definitely shocking and it kind
of blew me away but now that it's been a
couple of days i've got to say that it's
kind of growing on me and apparently an
apple developer confirmed that when
you're doing stuff like in full screen
mode either watching a movie watching a
video or playing any kind of game the
notch completely disappears because that
top section is completely black so it's
not going to distract you from your game
and everything below the notch is
actually in perfect 16 by 10 aspect
ratio so it's gonna scale perfectly just
like it did before and when you're doing
stuff like browsing the web or whatever
the notch is gonna show up but it's
going to be kind of blended into that
menu bar and now let's get into this
first comparison photo
boom
there you guys go we can see the new 14
inch on the left and we've got the old
13 inch like literally this thing
on the right and wow guys
look at that increase in real estate
wow that display just looks so much more
immersive and actually let me zoom in on
this look at how thin those bezels are
that's like literally almost twice it
actually might be twice as thin
dang that looks good all the way around
on the bottom and of course on the top
look at that difference in the bezel
wow and if we zoom out
we can kind of see why the notch is
there because that bezel is just so thin
and in reality you can see the webcam
right there i'm not sure if apple would
be able to honestly fit it inside that
little slim bezel because in reality the
lens is small but you also have the
sensor that's square behind it so they'd
be right up against the edge of the
frame so i guess it justifies the notch
i'm not saying it's amazing but it
justifies it because that extra screen
real estate
is worth it and as you can see the
macbook pro text is gone but i am
noticing that it's also much darker it's
a deeper black than the very gray kind
of backing the chin right over here so i
really really love that and it also
seems like the keys themselves are more
dark because if you look here they're
kind of grayish and kind of faded but
they're a very deep black so all of the
letters and numbers really seem to stand
out and of course the new black well
surrounding all the keys that is a
totally unique look and i really really
like that compared to having the silver
behind it that is really really cool and
it looks to be deeper
as well and as far as the size of the
chassis itself you can see that it's
actually wider this way and taller or
deeper that way so you're getting a
little bit of extra space right here and
the display is a little bit taller and
what that enabled apple to do
was add the function keys back the
physical function keys and they're no
longer half size you can see right here
on my macbook pro it's actually full
size all the way across
and we can also see that they've
switched out the little square touch id
button for a new larger one with a
little circle just like they have in the
new 24 inch imax magic keyboard so
that's definitely nice and another
little detail you can see is that the
speaker grilles are much wider on the
new 14 inch compared to these thin
speaker grilles and of course they are
getting much better speakers it's
getting the same speaker system as the
newly updated one in the 16 inch and as
far as i can tell the track pad is
identical on both of them but it kind of
looks like this new notch right here is
a little bit wider
than the other one now of course i'm
extremely excited for when we actually
get these macbook pros in especially
since we ordered eight of them different
configurations to test and compare and
make videos for you guys and we're
actually doing something special
something that i don't think we have
ever done before we are doing a giveaway
of one of those new macbook pros i'm not
sure which model but to enter the
giveaway we're basically going to be
posting a bunch of videos for launch
week next week and what we're going to
do is we're going to choose one of those
videos and then choose a random comment
and we're gonna do what we can to make
sure that the commenter is subscribed
and then we're gonna contact them and
basically ship them the new macbook pro
so if you are not subscribed yet
seriously do so right now so you don't
miss out so you can enter that giveaway
and that is truly going to help us to
reach our goal of a million subscribers
before the end of the year so please
subscribe if you appreciate all of our
efforts and with that said i do want to
mention that we just launched our brand
new m1 max tech t-shirt design which you
can find in the merch shelf below and we
have a promo code m1 pro to get 20 off
on all of our merch so be sure to do
that and i actually have the full
resolution image of that new design so
you guys can check it out and if you
like it please support us or you can buy
this sharpie edition so with that said
guys we're extremely excited for tuesday
when we get the very first macbook pro
that we're gonna get into this office
we're gonna do some crazy testing and
we're gonna be doing that giveaway so
hopefully you enjoyed this video with my
thoughts on the new design of the
14-inch macbook pro and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those
including the leaked benchmark video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one